-Our next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning
actress and singer you know from
shows like "Game of Thrones,"
"Sex Education,"
and ""Ted Lasso.
Her special "Home for Christmas"
is streaming now on Apple TV+.
Let's take a look.
-♪ Everybody's waitin'
for the man with the bag ♪
♪ 'Cause Christmas
is here again ♪
♪ He'll be here ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ With the answers
to the prayers ♪
♪ That you've made
through the year ♪
♪ You'll get yours ♪
♪ If you've done
everything you should ♪
♪ Extra special good ♪
♪ He'll make this December ♪
♪ The one you'll remember ♪
♪ The best and the merriest
you ever did have ♪
-Please welcome back to the show
Hannah Waddingham, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Mid-tempo music plays ]
♪♪
Welcome!
-Hello!
-I'm thrilled to have you here.
-We're in the flesh.
-Ooh!
We've done this once over Zoom.
-Yes.
-I did not realize
that I had actually seen you
in the flesh before, though,
because I saw you
onstage in "Spamalot."
-"Spamalot."
-Now back onstage,
a revival.
-Yeah, I'm going to try
and go and check it out,
because, I mean,
those were happy, happy,
exhausting vocal days.
-Yeah!
-You've never seen --
The Lady of the Lake
is a exhausting role.
-Oh, my God,
it is completely exhausting.
But don't tell
the producers this.
I 100% would have done it
for no money.
Some of the greatest days
of my life.
And Mr. Tim Curry.
-Mr. Tim Curry, I mean...
-King Arthur. It was fantastic.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Had the audience
in the palm of his hand
from the first second.
-Now, I've heard great things
about the revival.
Have you gone and seen shows
that you had been in originally?
Have you ever done this before,
where you go...
-Uh, no -- Yeah,
I have done a little bit,
but this one,
I've been kind of avoiding.
But I just think, you know,
it started here.
So I want to go back and
support this revival, you know,
and Eric Idle and I are
absolutely friends forever.
So, yeah, I need to go
and check it out
and take my little girl,
who I have here with me.
-Very exciting.
You have your little girl
in New York City for Christmas?
Is this is her first
Christmas in the city?
-Yes, it is.
-How is she liking it so far?
-She honestly -- I think my
brother that's come with us --
I think he's actually
even more excited.
Yesterday my brother was like,
"This is where they shot 'Elf!'"
And my daughter was like,
"Okay,"
because she's been here
quite a lot, you know?
So, yeah, my 52-year-old brother
was losing his mind.
-I remember, in
your dressing room,
he's like, "Have you met Elf?"
-Yeah, yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Do you, uh --
But I would imagine
London is lovely
at Christmastime.
-Oh, it's gorg-- but it's
a totally different vibe.
-Yeah.
-Here,
there's just something --
I was saying to my driver,
I was just like, "Here,
it doesn't matter.
It's like dirty bins,
but Christmas stuff, as well.
So you're like, "It's gritty.
It's New York."
-Sometimes, if
you're lucky enough,
a rat will run by
with a little sack of presents.
-Yeah, and some...
-Yeah.
-...little antlers going on.
-A lot of little antlers.
-Do you know what it is?
It's cute.
-Yeah, Mayor Adams has
an Antlers on Rats initiative.
[ Laughter ]
It's very exciting.
You -- I also heard --
I mean, I think everybody
in the building heard --
It was very exciting.
It was an "SNL,"
the Christmas episode.
Kate McKinnon was there.
But not just you,
but the whole "Ted Lasso"
cast was there.
-Yeah, we travel
in a nauseating pack.
-Yes It's really fun.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, we obviously saw
they were -- a bunch of them
were in your clip there
from your Christmas special.
-Yeah.
-But I think sometimes --
you know, again, all I've done,
all my casts in my life,
have been, like,
the live cast where I actually
spent all week together.
But you guys don't actually see
each other that much.
-No, we don't.
So, when we do,
we're just
like, "Nah, nah, nah."
We just -- I mean, sometimes
I think people think
it's contractual
that we spend time together.
You know, must maintain that.
But we just -- it's like
a feeding frenzy.
We just can't -- Even things
where we do Q&A's and stuff,
we're trying
to slip out the door
to start our evening together,
which is so lovely.
And I think that comes
through the camera
and that's why people have loved
Ted so much.
-Yeah, I think
that's really true.
-Yeah, we miss it.
-You do get that camaraderie.
-We miss it, Jason!
-Yeah!
-We miss it.
-We all miss it, Jason!
[ Laughter ]
Um, you got
the "Ted Lasso" cast job.
You also got
another guest star,
which I heard was
your daughter's insistence.
-Yeah.
I mean, when I said to her
I wanted to give her
the opportunity
to choose one of my guests
for my special,
I mean, that could
have gone horribly wrong.
I could have had, you know,
like a purple alligator
or something
turn up in a costume.
And she literally,
before I finished my sentence,
just went,
"Leslie Odom Jr., Mummy!"
So I was just like,
"I don't think
we'll be able to get him
because he's probably busy
doing a show.
But the call went out.
And you know, of all my guests,
I have to say,
I think his and my voices
really meld together.
Although I did, you know --
I know it was my special,
but I did have to think --
you literally --
like a competition-winner
Hannah.
When I had my microphone,
I was like...
[ Sings indistinctly ]
'Cause he's --
♪ he's dreamy ♪
-He is dreamy.
Now, do you attribute this
to your daughter
just having a very good ear
and saying, "I think
Leslie Odom Jr.
would be a good fit"?
-Yeah, because
you have to think of kind of
the shape of the show
and the vocal quality
of different people with you.
You know, Luke Evans
that I sing with,
I've known him
for 20 years in theater.
Sam Ryder, a great talent from
the U.K., from our Eurovision.
And so I wanted somebody
that I knew
was both Broadway feeding into,
you know, the stuff
that I've done here,
but also, you know,
with his own stuff out there.
And honestly, for Apple to have
given me the luxury of going,
"I would like this person,
this person, this person,
and I want it to be
at the London Coliseum"
was just dreamy.
-And so the London Coliseum
is a very important building
to you,
a very important theater.
-Yeah.
-So was it both
your parents performed there?
-No, no, my mum, my mum. Yeah.
Both her parents
were opera singers,
and she was a principal at
Covent Garden before I was born.
And then she spent 30 years
in the English National Opera
Chorus.
So I was there
from the age of 8,
sitting in
that beautiful theater.
And then, when we shot it,
my daughter was 8 at the time,
in May.
She was sitting in the box
that I sat in from the age of 8
until my mom retired
when I was 38.
-Wow.
-Which was insane.
And then my mom there --
bless her -- both my parents,
who were so heavily inflicted
with terrible illness,
my mum still with
fighting Parkinson's,
but they were there
at the back of the auditorium.
So the whole show is really
a love letter to her
and to them
and that building.
Yeah, because I wanted
it to have,
-- you know,
it had to have real heart.
The other Christmas specials
that there are,
you know, I have
no delusions of grandeur
that I come from
a very different world.
So I wanted to have
completely live vocals
that nobody has touched,
nobody's tweaked.
Everything was live
in that killer environment.
So, yeah, it's my little
Christmas kiss to everyone.
-Do a lot of opera singers
have opera singers as parents?
Is this something
that is passed down?
-I don't know,
but I know that I've had
a lot of judgment in my time,
even when I was doing this.
-Really?
-Yeah, my mum.
Like, my dad kind of
gives me a rib crusher.
My mom's just like,
doesn't that hurt?
You know, the kind of
the shouty singing.
-Oh, so"Doesn't that hurt?"
is not actual sympathy.
-Oh, no, no, no,
it's a way of saying.
"You should be singing properly
like I know you can."
-"Doesn't it hurt
to do it wrong?"
-Yeah, "Doesn't it hurt?
Wouldn't you rather
sound like me?"
And my dad was just like --
He said nothing
on my Broadway debut.
And then, the next night,
rib crusher
and went, "Much better
than last night."
-Oh, wow.
[ Laughter ]
-"Love you."
-That's pretty good.
I mean, the fact
that he sat on it
for a night
is very sweet.
-No, don't give him that.
-Okay, I won't.
You also recently sang
"O Holy Night"
in front of Prince William
and Kate Middleton.
More nerves, less nerves,
or at this point,
are you beyond nerves?
-Oh, no, I'm absolutely --
No, I think it gets worse.
The more established you get,
you feel like people
are like, "Okay."
-Yeah, yeah.
-But the thing that was lovely,
I've just hosted the
Earthshot Environmental Awards
for Prince William,
out in Singapore,
with lovely Sterling K. Brown.
-Oh, he's great.
-Yeah, he and I got on
like a house on fire.
So, it was the second time
I'd seen Prince William.
And I did say to him in the kind
of receiving line afterwards,
I was like, "Sir, I don't know
whether you're stalking me
or I'm stalking you."
-Uh-huh.
-And he was just like
[Chuckles].
[ Laughter ]
Probably shouldn't say
the word "stalking" to a royal.
-Yeah. I was going to say,
"And then security tackled you."
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I want to congratulate you.
Not only another Emmy nomination
for "Ted Lasso"
but a Golden Globe!
Golden Globe nomination!
-Yeah! Come on, the gala! Yes!
-Very exciting.
-I cannot be cool about it
at all.
-I love that you
can't be cool about.
-I'm absolutely not cool at all,
because of the people
in the category.
-I hate when people
get nominated
and are like, "You know what?
It's just an honor
to do the work."
You're like, "Come on."
-No, it's not.
Am I allowed to swear?
-Yeah. Go [Bleep].
-[Bleep] epic.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know what's great?
When people curse
in a British accent,
we don't even have to beep it.
-No, just sounds more classy.
-It just sounds classy,
the way you say it.
You have some competition.
-There's a very little-known
actress in my category --
and I hope she's going to
do great things --
called Meryl Streep.
Yes.
-I feel like
that's very exciting.
That's almost like
an extra Emmy nomination
if you find yourself
into a category with Streep.
The Globes or the Emmys.
-It's the greatest win-win,
because if she doesn't win,
hilariously,
then you're like, "Hello,
I'm in a losing category
with Meryl Streep."
But if she does, you're like,
"Guys, Meryl Streep won."
-You're leaving out
the third option --
you win and then,
the whole night,
you're like,
"I'm better than Meryl."
-[Bleep] epic!
-Forever!
[ Laughter ]
Congratulations.
I think it's so much better
to have you here in person.
-Thank you.
-Hannah Waddingham, everybody.
"Home for Christmas"
is streaming now
on Apple TV+.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."